[Musique]
gros plan sur un terme important du
lexique de la désinformation le
blanchiment d'information vous
connaissez jeff le blanchiment d'argent
auxerrois en général ça c'est clair mais
le blanchiment d'information coutume en
dise plus là c'est quoi ce concept qui
est un peu semblable au blanchiment
d'argent donc avec le blanchiment
d'argent on essaie de masquer la
provenance d'argent illégal ou louche
avec le management des formations c'est
la même chose on essaie de mars qui une
source propre ya donc par exemple
faisons que on détient une information
d'une source lochon veut écrire un
article là dessus on a l'air un peu nos
deux cités cette source le choc
donc pourquoi pas citer un autre site
qui a cité cette source le donc ça nous
permet de masquer la source de
l'information et nous on adore faire
patte blanche avant
mais pour que ça se matérialise casse
manifeste le comment concrètement ça se
construit ce dans une chaîne de michel
de blanchiment d'information les
champions de sas et les tabloïds
britanniques donc s'en sont bien connus
pour écrire des articles vraiment
farfelues sur des histoires scabreuses
champ gauche et où sa gêne pas de citer
des sources qui sont pas souvent pas
très fiables le problème c'est que bon
les tables thonet que ce sont de vrais
journaux et donc les autres médias de la
planète se gênent pas de citer les
tabloïds britanniques parce que ce sont
des choses qui sont généralement fiables
donc ça fait que ça masque la source de
l'information quand on dit selon le
daily mirror de l'histoire a eu lieu ça
masque le fait que la source originale
était pas fiable
l'exemple le plus abracadabra que j'ai
vu c'était en 2015 à propos d'un bébé en
chine qui avaient été aveuglé par le
flash d'une caméra
ok donc c'est une somme qui avait été
reprise dans les tableaux si ce n'est
qu'ils avaient été repris par les médias
ici ou au québec mais la chaîne
d'information là dedans est absolument
époustouflant d'écouter les médias
québécois ont cité le daily mail le
dernier on connaît son information
people's daily online sept chinois
oui c'était le quang minh débris un
journal local en chine qui lui se base
sur un site qui s'appelle kioukiou point
com qui lui se baser sur un site qui
s'appelle des ahp point com qui est un
blog en garde les slams et mais en
conclusion la caisse contient tout ça
ben il faut qu'on essaie nous même de
remonter à la source originale le plus
possible donc on n'a pas toujours le
temps d'aller faire ça mais quand on lit
un article
et l'article 10 selon tel ce premier
temps de cliquer sur le site
regardez c'est fiable ou au mieux de
notre habilité le remonter à la source
originale parce que ça me donne la
meilleure idée de la fiabilité de tous